- All right,
everyone take a seat.
- Wait, why does Justin
have a church in his house?
- And why does the cross
have a little foot on it?
- Oh, that's a "T" for Theroux,
because Justin believes
in himself so much.
- Ugh, ew. Can we just go
back down to the living room?
- No, there's a lot
of bad stuff in this binder,
and I don't want Chase to hear.
Now, I want
to start with Cary.
- Great, yes, I've done
a lot of bad things.
Um, when I was 11 years old,
I would get boners in church
because one of the altar boys
was super hot, so I would
just tuck my dick
up into my belt
during communion.
- Cary.
- I know which altar boy.
- And when was in
the eighth grade,
we took a class trip
to Water World,
and I purposefully rode
the log flume
with my friend Kevin's dad
so I could buy
the picture afterwards
and masturbate to it.
- Oh, honey,
did you hear he died?
- I did.
And when I was 23,
I worked at a hotel
and Christopher Meloni
stayed there,
and one day he went
out to the pool,
so I snuck into his room
and smelled his underwear.
But then he returned
to a different room,
so I don't know
whose underwear I smelled.
- Oh, my God.
Cary, let me cut to the chase.
- Ooh, we should
trademark that, my God.
- I meant things
I could find online.
You just described three
private, sad moments.
How would I find those things?
- Oh.
Then...
I'm just kidding.
- You know what, I didn't find
anything bad on you.
- Good.
- You can go do
your little play,
but, Cary, please have sex.
- I'm trying.
- I know something bad
that I did online.
- Good luck, babe.
- Beth Kellogg from church
is always posting photos
of these ducks in her yard.
So one night, I did have
a little glass of wine,
I commented,
"Enough with the ducks,"
and then I unfriended her.
I already had
to change churches,
and now I'm so worried
it's gonna ruin Chase's career.
- Awww, that is absolutely
not in this binder.
- Ah.
- Every single thing in here
is about Brooke.
- Oh.
- Excuse me?
No, my whole thing
is smart, young progressive.
So I don't know what
you think you found,
but...was it my Gchats?
- Nope.
- Oh, then I'm golden.
Come at me.
- You used the word
"retarded" on Twitter
no less than 56 times.
- I mean, are we sure
that was me?
- Your first tweet was,
"Twitter is retarded.
Come at me."
- Ooh.
Well, that was
a long time ago.
Now I'm a social
justice warrior.
People on Twitter
always tell me
I'm a classic white feminist.
- That's not good.
And we deleted that account.
- What?
- I also deleted
photos of you from Halloween
as Terri Schiavo.
- What?
- Okay, I went as
Terri Schiavo before,
and then I happened
to pass out at the party.
- Okay, shall I continue?
- Well, if you
have anything else.
- Let's talk about
your LiveJournal.
- Oh, no.
- What do you mean?
He's our brother.
- Keep your voice down.
He's been through enough.
- He has a right to know.
- No, we have to protect him.
[cell phone buzzes]
That's what family does.
So it's settled.
We decide tomorrow.
- Agreed. Brian?
- No.
- No?
- You think I want to say no?
Like some kind of sick freak?
- Of course not, but--
- But nothing!
We decide the day
after tomorrow.
- And finally,
your Venmo account.
- Okay, what could I have
possibly done wrong on Venmo?
- Every time you pay Cary
for anything,
you write that it's for
"slamming that puss."
- Brooke.
- Well, okay.
That is just sibling humor.
- We deleted
that account too.
- [sighs]
- And that's it.
- Really?
I'm okay?
- Well, karmically, you need
to do some soul searching.
- Yeah.
- Optically, we're fine.
- Okay.
- All right.
Let's call Yendani, people.
- This is gonna be so romantic.
[beep]
- Hi, Yendani.
- Hey, Chase.
- Okay, kids, so tonight
we'll start off
with Instagram live,
and then tomorrow I have you
on the red carpet
for the Hot 97 Summer Jam.
- Oh, my God,
I love Summer Jam.
Okay, one year I got so drunk,
and I went home with this guy,
but I was dating somebody else,
and so I waited until
he was asleep to kiss him.
That way it wasn't cheating.
[laughs]
- That's sexual assault.
- Oh, oh.
No, no, you're confused.
I'm a girl,
and he just wasn't awake.
And I kissed him, so...
- Yeah, no,
that's sexual assault.
- You know, you make
a great point, Yendani,
and we're gonna take a break
and just think about that.
So...
Okay, we're on mute now.
So everybody keep smiling
and don't move your lips,
'cause this is very bad.
- Am I doing it?
Are my lips moving?
- Oh, I gotta get
those pictures.
Who do I gotta suck?
Who do I gotta [bleep]?
- There are no pictures.
- Did he wake up
and file a report?
- No, he doesn't know.
Like, nobody knows.
- Oh, nobody knows?
Okay, ooh.
- Oh, okay.
- Who gives a shit?
- Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
- No, we're not fine.
Yendani said it.
I committed sexual assault.
- But no one knows.
- But I know.
And strong, powerful women
like me and Yendani,
we don't do stuff like this.
I have to go tell him.
Someone DVR "Real Housewives
of Atlanta" for me.
- I don't think Justin has DVR.
- Damn it.